[Music]
not sexy honey dump him immediately
Kristen Davis wishes she could help end
the long-standing feud between Sex and
the City co-star Sarah Jessica Parker
and Kim Cattrall I want you to be maid
of honor
how do you feel about that same way you
feel about Botox painful and unnecessary
in an interview with the telegraph Davis
says she wishes she could fix things
adding
you have to respect people's wishes I'm
not gonna waste energy on it I can't
change anybody I do understand fans
feelings that they are upset I wish I
could fix it but I can't it's not in my
power
[Music]
is unbothered by the reports of her
rumored romance with Bill Murray the
singer is breaking her silence while
responding to a fan on Instagram
while enjoying her vacation in Greece a
fan commented on her post asking ma'am
would you care to address these Bill
Murray allegations cause damn what he
doing with all that and in a playful
response Khali says LOL no babe I
wouldn't bother at all added another
response to the rumors that media
attention police writes LOL yeah maybe
for now everyone's dumb and will believe
anything but the best part is we are
both blessed rich and happy so who's
really laughing now that's funny
the rumors began last week after Murray
was seen attending a Kelis concert
overseas but he has yet to address the
alleged new Romance